hi I'm Eric Vox and as we wait for the
Walking Dead Season seven to return on
February 12 recently executive producer
Gale Anne Hurd revealed that they
actually toned down the level of
violence on the show following the
deaths in the season premiere and
obviously spoiler alert if you aren't
caught up yet so heard actually admitted
that after the negative response to the
brutality of negan bludgeoning Glenn and
Abraham producers made adjustments to
episodes that were still in production
at the time of the October 23rd premiere
she said we were able to look at the
feedback on the level of violence we did
tone it down for episodes we were still
filming for later on in the season heard
also defended the show saying that it
isn't torture porn and that they're very
wary of crossing that line so I'm going
to speculate on what those changes might
have been in a bit but first let's ask
ourselves is the Walking Dead too
violent no it isn't in the video bye bye
roll credits
but obviously the answer isn't that
simple right so let's dig deeper into
this so the deaths of Glenn and Abraham
seemed like the peak of particularly
extreme deaths that have been a staple
on the show since the first season
specifically trigger warning because I'm
about to show you a lot of gross stuff
Andrea's sister Amy the governor are
getting stabbed in the eye Hershel
everything in terminus
Noah Sam and Jesse Nicholas Denise and
all the Savior's that were brutally
slaughtered in season six not to mention
the more emotionally horrific deaths of
characters like Sophia Laurie Lizzie and
mica and Beth like the more vulnerable
the victim or the closer to the face
sore head that the injury occurs the
harder of these death started really to
look at and Glenn and Abraham getting
their skull bashed in seems like a
natural result of this trend and really
aside from Abraham this violence is
pretty much how it goes down to the
comics the eyeball popping out a
splatter brains
Glenn's brain damage goodbye to Maggie
yeah but let's be honest the show
definitely took liberties with how Biv
idli they shot this like buckets of red
blood and brain goo are way more extreme
than the black and white comics the
sound the bat made is a crack of skulls
the motion of Megan swings and Glenn's
hand twitching Greg Nicotero and his
team definitely knew what they were
doing with all this stuff they loved
seeing how far they can go with it and a
lot more people watched the TV show than
the core comic readers millions of
viewers had huge attachment to Glenn and
Abraham and seeing them die was a lot
more heartbreaking than the deaths of
Beth or Lori or Shane or Tabitha the
goat but that's exactly why the show did
this Megan's arrival wouldn't have had
much of an impact without some
especially tragic death and some
familiar faces just needed to go to
signal the transition of a new world
order under negan and Rick and the gang
needed to be shaken from their status
quo enough to be driven to wage war
against negan sorry but Denis just
wasn't enough of a motivator and that
narrative justification is what keeps
the Walking Dead from becoming torture
porn the deaf must drive the story
forward or reveal character in a way
that the show otherwise would have been
able to it can't just be for shock value
or to keep fans guessing who's going to
die next or to make a grim statement
about how hopeless and up this world is
so really it's not so much the death
itself that matters it's what comes
after how the story processes the death
so here's an example of when The Walking
Dead
pulled this off well a year ago the
mid-season premiere of season six showed
us several horrifically violent events
one right after the other
Sam got gobbled up Jessie got her hand
chopped off and then got gobbled up too
then was shown stabbed run and then Ron
shot Carl's eye out this was a pretty
huge moment of defeat for Rick and for
us the Alexandria safe zone had fallen
its leader was dead and the group was
scattered but what happened next
Rik rallied the citizens of Alexandria
to fight their way through the Horde
Walker by Walker until the gang was
reunited and the area was clear the
episode ended with Rick's hopeful
bedside speech to Carl and Carl waking
up from his coma so in this episode the
deaths and Carl's bloody LASIK were all
necessary to drive Rick to rise as the
leader of Alexandria and to gain a
vision for the future death led to life
and while we don't have to complete that
arc in one great episode it's kind of
pushing it to stretch that payoff across
the whole half season which is where
season seven kind of ran into trouble so
rather than following up Glenn and
Abraham shockingly violent deaths with a
direct narrative consequence of like
Rick rallying a resistance or honestly
just a lot more negan the show slowed
things down putting negan scenes on the
back burner and focus on storylines that
were honestly a little disconnected from
the main narrative and that brings me
back to the changes that were made to
Season seven now I have a theory that by
tinkering with the episodes to make them
a little less dark and violent after
Glenn and Abraham death the show
ironically left out crucial elements
that we needed for Glenn Abraham's
deaths to have meaning now to be clear I
think establishing the kingdom and
Oceanside and Maggie's leadership at the
hilltop were all necessary world
building steps that were always part of
the plan for season seven and I really
don't think the producers were like oh
people were upset about negan killing
Glenn so let's swap in this palate
cleanser at the kingdom instead really I
wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
changes were just tweaking little
moments like in episode 7 cutting away
from the hot iron the moment negan fix
it on marks face and only showing when
it pulls away or in episode 8 cutting
away from Fat Joe II when Daryl kills
him with the pole or maybe there was a
somehow even grosser version of
Spencer's guts spilling out that we
didn't see but looking back at the half
season there were a few moments that
were just oddly paced or logically
confusing for example let's look back at
episode 3 with Dwight imprisoning Daryl
at the sanctuary with everyone's
favorite torture song
now I actually like this episode when I
first saw it but a few things seemed to
be missing
for starters Dwight spends most of this
episode hunting down this runaway Savior
Gordon but as viewers we have no idea
who this guy is
until Dwight catches up to him and
executes them his death has limited
emotional impact because we're only
learning now how they know each other
you would think there would need to be
an earlier scene to establish who Gordon
is but the only other moment that we saw
Gordon this episode was very briefly in
that opening music video montage
[Music]
but I think most of us didn't initially
connect that that was the same guy and
when you look at it closely this music
video montage seems a little off
[Music]
now the who's the boss imagery and the
song choice were all super interesting
and check out my breakdown on that
episode for more on that but I just
don't think these shots were originally
intended to be part of a montage like
notice how while this is all edited like
a music video with repetition and cut
synced with the beat of the song all of
these shots aren't really connected
logically and it takes a few watches of
it to really understand that dwight
watched another savior step out of line
and then wrote down his bunk number to
raid his food and assemble a sandwich
and i might be totally wrong but i think
that all of these moments were
originally shot as separate themes that
each independently showed a different
aspect of life under negan like one
scene with dwight playing this drinking
game with this random savior woman
trying to maybe distract himself from
the fact that negan took his wife and
then another scene establishing gordon
at the farm maybe talking [ __ ] about
negan and asking Dwight how to escape
and then another couple scenes where
Dwight watches that red haired Savior
get jumped and then he loses bunk in
front of the guy's family now again this
could just be me reading into things and
maybe it was always written to be a
montage and it just didn't connect
clearly enough to the viewer or maybe
these scenes were just merged to save
time but considering AMC was pretty cool
with plenty of other episodes running
along the season my theory is that this
sequence was re-edited for total reason
either there was an extremely violent
moment from negan that the producers
didn't want so close after glennon
Abraham's death or maybe these scenes
were just too grim and dark and the
producers instead chose to open this
episode with a light-hearted fun sitcom
a music video
and I totally respect that choice like
this music and the montage were super
enjoyable and I just love seeing who's
the boss show up in the walking dead but
looking back this was a bit of a missed
opportunity episode 3 was the first we
saw of negan and his men following the
bloody premiere and really the show
could have used this moment who clearly
reinforced Megan's character and his
sick ideology and to retroactively Li
define Glenn and Abraham as casualties
and martyrs in a very violent war with a
very evil warlord instead the episode
open with this ironically lighthearted
montage that only vaguely hints at
negan's insanity while confusing us
about the Savior's social structure and
the unfortunate effect of all this is
we're left uncertain how to feel about
negan or whether Glenn and Abraham's
graphic deaths were really intended to
establish the savagery of a new villain
or were just for shock value now again I
don't think the Walking Dead is too
violent I respect that when you're
making a TV show with a rabid fan base
adapting a source material with its own
rabid fan base it's really hard to
balance all the elements to keep
everyone satisfied and to make every
moment on the show count and based on
how season 7 left things in the
mid-season finale I feel pretty
confident that the show is now on the
right track toward making the shocking
violence of the season premiere account
and if that means even more violence I'm
honestly okay with that okay what do you
think about this do you think the
Walking Dead is becoming too violent are
you okay with the violence so long as
three standards are met and did you
notice that the violence might have been
toned down after the first episode let
me know your thoughts in the comments
also be sure to check out my breakdowns
of all the episodes of The Walking Dead
Season 7 episode 9 will premiere on
February 12th and I'll be back with more
breakdowns if you like this video please
hit like and subscribe to new rockstars
and make sure you're getting an email
notification we would very much
appreciate it if you shared this video
with all your friends or if you feel
super generous contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons especially pony start
you can hit me up on Twitter a TA Vox
with any general thoughts you have on
the walking dead or following new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on when our videos are coming
out alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you